Прогулянка на човні Босфором нагадує подорож історією Стамбула.
Вражаючі маєтки, що вкрили береги цієї протоки, турецькою називають яліс.
Багато з них звели ще в епоху Османської імперії - для заможних власників.
Нині ці вілли є одними з найдорожчих та найексклюзивніших об’єктів нерухомості,
які може запропонувати Стамбул.
Але після валютної кризи, що сталася в Туреччині минулого року,
багато власників намагаються продати свої маєтки.
Те, що для одних - криза, для інших - можливість заробити.
Угур Айхан - брокер елітної нерухомості.
А Тарік Аль-Фадель представляє потенційних покупців з Близького Сходу.
Ось ця вілла, яку вони оглядають сьогодні - одна з найбільш "скромних".
Тут 8 кімнат з двома кухнями. Багато мармуру. І величезний причал для приватної яхти.
За цю віллу просять 130 мільйонів турецьких лір. Це приблизно 21 мільйон євро.
Нині близько 60 з шести сотень віл продаються у Стамбулі.
Зараз ціни нижчі, передусім через те, що ліра втратила в ціні. Тому попит високий.
Драматичні зміни на ринку нерухомості - не єдина причина.
Хоча багато турків більше не можуть собі дозволити купувати вілли на Босфорі,
продажі іноземцям зросли майже на 80 відсотків - передусім покупцям з арабського світу.
Турецький уряд нещодавно оголосив,
що іноземці, які купують нерухомість за більш ніж 250 тисяч євро,
можуть отримати турецьке громадянство.
Мої клієнти зараз вкладаються у нерухомість.
Вони переконані, що якщо вони зараз інвестують чималі гроші - це буде вигідно в майбутньому.
Турецька економіка та ліра рано чи пізно відновляться і тоді інвестиції окупляться.
Існує ще одна причина, чому босфорські вілли такі популярні -
особливо серед покупців з Близького Сходу.
Багато арабів знайомі з цими віллами з турецьких телесеріалів.
Їх постійно транслюють по телебаченню в арабських країнах,
бо люди шаленіють від них.
Іноді мої клієнти телефонують і кажуть мені: "Я хочу купити цю віллу з мого улюбленого серіалу".
Перегляд завершено на сьогодні.
Два ріелтори мають намір продовжувати торги.
Тож, ймовірно, що цей маєток з вражаючим видом на Босфор незабаром змінить свого господаря.